I grew up in the Wavertree
area and the toxic areas as a kid Smith
download Laden sold bail rolled around
the lodge lane area maybe the person I
am today still loved the area me mother
still lives there I am ultimately a
product of my environment I faced a
little [ __ ]
and then I'm someone who loves a fight
[Music]
I wouldn't change my opinion for the
world
well ultimately a yes it was tough and I
was helped a little after me from places
like youth sentences I spent an awful
lot of my time playing football with the
sum of the logs out here today going to
youth centers places like the Rodney
places like the wreck they're places
like Dr Hill there's just so many
different places now 90% replacing our a
shutdown or knock down there's no place
for the kids normal or not let us out hi
I'm a product man we went down places
and alls we done was fight play football
fights play more football
I'm trying talk to the old girl every
blue moon so that that's just what our
lives are the boss kids go on and there
I definitely think it's mainly the
grounder person and I'll never forget
where I'm from ever in a million years
on there I'm still operating and still
within the same place I'm from as well
[Music]
and this is where I grew up as a kid Wow
this road looks ocean man that's me
mother's house number 39 that's where I
grow see ya you see for me is where the
[ __ ] embellish it all of it is now is
[ __ ] the ship end
shite
you don't understand me I hate them I'm
de haters
the only difference I'd rotate the team
the fans me dad's on the pill fan so I
can't really I love [ __ ] fights this
place has changed lives children from in
session and coaches room the glove room
stinks tough room you come through here
you see these vests international best
boxing for our country and then we've
got the two rings and up the back is the
man himself - picture - Jimmy the icon
the legend the man who the face that I
walked in the a I asked Jimmy Albertina
how long til a box and he said maybe 12
18 months I walk by how the gym it
didn't come back for like six months
stayed on them for the next few years
and then three years that's what I
realized how good of a baby and that's
how it was all bow to him without these
four walls in this gym you know my
locker probably be locked off today
without this place then I after the
would have after their money either the
hard way or the fast way either way it
wouldn't have been good so we kind of
created the mood that the fight at the
city for a finale and the movie
acquisition Park and I was like I was
thinking well you know I for two
Goodison Park I've got this close I
still never thought it would be possible
to actually get that ring on the pitch
and I'm a real fight and there
especially the WBC world title while I'm
fighting for nests yeah it's just a
dream come true
we're nearly there now it's a ideally I
just want to stick the ring in the
middle of the pitch and those clothes
absolutely ma'am five thousand on the
pitch listen I don't do and I step out
of that song
on Sunday the 29th of May this I'm not
gonna be able to hit anyone I'm just
gonna hear the roar so I'm gonna come
out of that tunnel I'm just gonna stand
there just have a nice look around and
erase it and go to where I'm gonna
become world champion in background and
it's gonna be remembered forever no one
can ever take that away from me I'm
gonna fight the goodness important I'm
gonna become world champion and now it's
gonna be the icing on the cake if I die
the next day I die a happy man that's
the best way of saying I am ultimately a
product of my environment have face tea
little [ __ ]
and then I'm someone who loves a fight
[Music]